what's shaking man
not much man thank you for having me
especially my first time speaking to you
so
yeah i just i don't know i mean i i was
just watching you i mean the reason why
you just started because i usually
engage with you but the reason why i
just
got onto this one it's because you know
the email you were reading about this
guy
and you know if you've previously done
this you know the last one was like
about this woman who had all these smart
things to say
but i'm just sort of curious like i
remain just
destined to sort of end up this way
because usually
i'm pretty sure that a lot of these guys
have come across someone
pretty similar to you like someone who's
like pro you know man's right or
whatever
they've heard these things before but
usually they just think that okay yeah i
get that i get it they're a woman like
that but my
significant other maybe the exception
usually that's the mentality that
men would have until they end up you
know getting
screwed over in which case they're
coming you know with their tails between
their legs and so now they want to
listen to you when it's a little too
late
right so i mean i don't know because
and you also attribute that to like you
know man being raised by single mothers
or whatever
but we have to also acknowledge that a
lot of fathers too
raise their sons you know with this sort
of mentality you know this guy
yeah there's a lot of weak fathers out
there that are definitely contributing
to this problem
yeah and i'm i'm like how do you sort of
like try to fix this
problem because you know in many cases
men in particular they're going to try
to search for people like you
once they've already been dumped once
they've already you know once
it's kind of a little too late for them
to like you know because usually people
get into problems or whatever
they're not going to speak for someone
like you here's the thing about the red
pill
is it's not a vitamin it's a
prescriptive medication to solve an
ailment right like people take vitamins
they take vitamin c and zinc and vitamin
d
to prevent themselves from getting
coveted right right you go and take
you know uh prescription medicines
painkillers you know essentially
to deal with the problem that you've
created and that's when they come to
this so
you know your to your earlier point i
think you changed the name of your um
your screen name because you had a point
to address on whether men
are just destined to end up this way was
that you yeah that that was me actually
it's
like cereal yeah yeah yeah um for the
most part yeah
men are destined to complicate their
lives and justify why they do it and
that's not going to change for the
vast majority of the population dude it
wouldn't matter if i had
like 10 million subscribers and a
billion views on my channel
that doesn't even put a dent into
anything right because i still
feel like you know even though they're
just pretty aware i mean there's just
like the
impulse to like want to get what they
wanted just like guys love simping man
yeah i love bending the knee to women
they've always been disposable
throughout history we've always been
treated as disposable it's in our dna
to basically throw ourselves at the feet
of women and society
like a little [ __ ] and let society and
women
do with us you know what they please
it's it's
guys like me that say hey you know what
put yourself first you know like rose
says you know
make yourself your own mental point of
origin that's what shakes it up a bit
that's what makes it better for guys
that's how they have better experiences
in life
right but even some men who are already
aware of like what's
out there they usually just sort of
slowly sort of get themselves in the
hole because you know okay i'm just
gonna do this but not cross this line
because i know what
this is all about or whatever then the
next time they get a little closer and
closer and closer
until the point where they just end up
screwed up although so
i just don't know at this point like it
this is what you like the bottleneck for
you know yeah but like what are you
concerned with like why do you care is
my question like why do you care that
are meant
that men are destined to like become
this
weak version of themselves like why
aren't you focused on yourself
i mean i am focused on myself actually i
mean i'm
studying i mean i'm a young guy studying
college i mean i'm pretty aware like i'm
like when i see somebody that's just
about to destroy their life
and i ask him a question like hey man
did you uh you know did you think this
one through did you take a look at a
prenup
right and they kind of cast it aside and
blah blah and they're like no i'm fully
in love
i'm fully committed to this this isn't
going anywhere i'm not worried about
this i don't care that she's a
hairdresser and i make quarter million
dollars a year
it doesn't matter to me it's like okay
at least i just opened the door to see
if you wanted to take a look at a few
things inside that
hallway you don't want to look at it
that's cool man you go and [ __ ] up your
life
and like on a lot of cases they're like
they know that you know this is the
right thing to do but just don't want to
upset their significant other by just
sort of giving the impression that they
their significant other is going to like
be a little greedy or whatever yeah it's
totally fine
you just have to let it go i mean you
just have to you know get yourself to
the point where
you know you realize that you've only
got so much energy in a given day to
allocate to things that are worth your
attention
and you only reserve your attention and
energy for those things
that's it you know i covered that in in
my how to give fewer f's chapter in my
book
yeah by the way i'm just uh i just
ordered your book on amazon
i actually it was really some of the
reviews they're just amazing
all right well thank you for having my
call i appreciate it all right eli
thanks man see you later
bye peace
you